ein jahr pandemie hat unsere welt
verändert die menschheit tritt in ein
neues zeitalter ihrer hilflos gegen
einen unsichtbaren feind
das virus wird bleiben das wird sich
weiter verändern den verschiedenen
varianten regierungen ratlos systeme
gestört die welt und ihre wirtschaft im
stillstand
wer kommt besser aus der krise
demokratien stehen unter stress genauso
wie jeder einzelne von uns überall
wachsen ungeduld und unruhe über lok
downs oder lockerungen auf uns zu haus
und runter das verträgt keine
gesellschaft auf dauer kann das virus
die welt aus den angeln heben oder
lernen wir das zu beherrschen
[Musik]
wo china ein virus überwindet die alten
grenzen
woher wann und wie ist unbekannt
wenn es nur einen weg gebe es schnell
wieder loszuwerden
sie sprühen und desinfizieren ganz
johann ist auf der jagd nach
unsichtbaren keimen tag und nacht
noch weiß keiner was kommen wird aber
die befehle sind eindeutig sprühen und
spülen wieder und wieder
im dauer einsatz mit schwerem gerät
herum und sein team von der
umweltbehörde
im kampf gegen das virus das sich rasant
ausbreitet desinfizieren sie die straßen
von guan wir haben heute schon 14 mal
die straße gereinigt
wir haben viele solcher fahrzeuge im
einsatz den markt von buer an der
millionenstadt am young zu haben die
behörden flugs abgeriegelt noch soll
niemand wissen die ernstes ist vor allem
nicht ausländische journalisten
und da war alles abgesperrt da war
wieder diese gespenstische atmosphäre du
sahst die menschen in diesen vollen
anzügen ja du sagst überall polizei wir
wollten papier da machen nur mit dem
handy
und schon das war sehr sehr schwierig
wir sind zweimal vorbei gefahren
beim dritten mal merken wir schon die
polizei guckt uns an und wir müssen
aufpassen wie sich später herausstellte
wussten die behörden viel viel mehr
heute weiß man dass man viel viel mehr
infiziert als offiziell jemals zugegeben
worden sind mitte januar ist bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die
zuversicht noch groß dass die ganze
sache nicht allzu schlimm wird ja eine
übertragung von mensch zu mensch ist
begrenzt möglich
aber das ist keine überraschung wir sind
bereit die kleine zu aktivieren und die
werkzeuge zu nutzen die wir für saas und
märz entwickelt haben
ingo hahn sind die krankenhäuser
hoffnungslos überlastet aus den
staatlichen medien erfährt die
bevölkerung nichts davon
privatleute bringen diese aufnahmen nach
draußen
[Musik]
die whu hat leider keine glückliche
figur gemacht in dieser pandemie am
anfang bestand das problem darin dass
dieser sogenannte internationale
gesundheitsnotfall zu spät ausgerufen
wurde da gab es ja am 22 januar eine
sitzung des notfall-komitees dort hat
der chinesische vertreter darum gebeten
dass man diesen notfall nicht aus ruft
etwas ähnliches ist später bei der
erklärung der pandemie passiert so haben
viele versucht das auf die leichte kappe
erstmal zu nehmen in wohin fahren die
bagger auf viele bagger für große
krankenhäuser
die regierung weiß längst dass etwas
großes eingedrungen ist
erst wollten sie das virus vertuschen
nun wollen sie es vernichten
ich glaube die chinesen haben aus ihrer
sicht schon das richtige getan weil sie
ja zunächst mal ihre eigene bevölkerung
schützen wollten und dann sind sie ja in
einem für unsere verhältnisse sehr
heftigen lockdown gegangen
heute können wir das bisschen
nachvollziehen damals erschien uns dass
er massiv diese diese eingriffe aber das
richtige haben sie natürlich schon
gemacht was sie selbst denn das wäre was
ja losgeworden
mit trachten maßnahmen wie man sie
wahrscheinlich nur den einen autoritären
land machen kann nämlich dass du elf
millionen menschen wohin über
zweieinhalb monate ein [ __ ] das musst
du dir vorstellen ein spaß die kommen
nicht mehr aus und das wurde ja über
nacht verhängt und das sind leute
stecken geblieben also würdest quasi
heute sagen jeder der in mainz ist muss
da bleiben ist da wäre chaos die wohl
nach hause die müssen irgendwo was
einkaufen das ist die brutalität der
maßnahmen ist das erfolgsrezept
das virus ist neu altbekannt unser
umgang mit gefahren außerhalb von china
wurden insgesamt 50 fälle gemeldet
darunter in australien nordamerika und
europa zwei der infizierten patienten
liegen in dieser pariser klinik unter
quarantäne einer in bordeaux
einer nach dem anderen belgien island
saudi arabien senegal melden die ersten
fälle und noch ist jeder auch ein fall
für die nachrichten
wir können nicht davon ausgehen dass
krone einen bogen um unser land machen
wird
und so beginnt die zeit der abschottung
mit grenzkontrollen
einreisebeschränkungen kontakt verboten
quarantäne globalisierung im
rückwärtsgang
kontakte nach außen sind plötzlich
riskant und wie immer in krisenzeiten
suchen menschen nach den schuldigen und
wie meistens sind das die anderen im
chinesischen netz kursieren videos von
sogenannten schutzmaßnahmen
wir machen die tür zugeht zurückgeht
zurück die maßnahmen gegen menschen aus
wohin sind massiv auf dem schild steht
diese familie war in wuchern bitte nicht
mit ihnen in berührung kommen aus angst
vor dem virus werden haustüren und ganze
häuser verbarrikadiert
in russlands viertgrößter stadt
jekaterinburg haben die kosaken den
kampf gegen das corona virus aufgenommen
zweimal wöchentlich patroullieren sie
dort wo sie viele chinesische
einwanderer vermuten asiaten seien
anfälliger für das virus als russen
behaupten sie seit dem auftreten des
corona virus beklagen sich immer mehr
asiaten in frankreich über anfeindungen
und diskriminierungen zum beispiel in
der metro die gegenüber sitzenden
passagiere haben sich den schal vor dem
mund gebunden
ganz viele meiner freunde werden auf
offener straße beleidigt man sagt zu
ihnen sie sollten doch heimgehen mit
ihrem virus das sehen wir in allen
kulturen überall auf der welt dass
menschen versuchen sich vor dem
außenseiter zu schützen
in bestzeiten im mittelalter hat man die
juden zum verursacher des problems
erklärt als im 19 jahrhundert die
cholera wütete wurden die ärzte
angegriffen weil man ihnen vorwarf sie
hätten die krankheit in die welt gesetzt
um die armen auszurotten immer versuchen
menschen die schuld auf andere
abzuwälzen
als corona die usa erreicht deklariert
ist der präsident zum china virus und
macht die europäer für die verbreitung
verantwortlich die europäische union hat
es versäumt die selben
vorsichtsmaßnahmen zu treffen wie wir
und reisen aus china und anderen
hotspots zu verbieten und so haben
reisende aus europa neue infektionsherde
verursacht
überall auf der welt rücken die
desinfektions kommandos aus
es weiß ja keiner wie dem neuen virus
beizukommen ist
ungewissheit und unruhe verunsichern die
politik und sind sand im getriebe der
wirtschaft
lieferketten sind unterbrochen grenzen
und märkte zu europa ohne antwort auch
an den finanzmärkten hat die korona
epidemie heftige folgen der dax erlebte
einen der schwärzesten tage seiner
geschichte und schloss fast 8 prozent im
minus nachdem der handel sogar
unterbrochen wurde gibt der dow jones
index an der wall street derzeit knapp
sieben prozent nach auf der ja aber hier
herrscht eine extreme verunsicherung
panik kontrollverlust rezession das sind
die worte die ihr den ganzen tag die
runde gemacht haben einmal die
restriktionen ab mitte märz 2020 und
dann auch der plötzliche absturz der
aktienmärkte der zumindest
wirtschaftlich so ein bisschen ein weg
ufer wo alle kapiert haben hier passiert
was dramatisches denn gerade
finanzmärkte schauen in die zukunft und
sind häufig ein maß davon was wir für
die kommenden monate und jahre zu
erwarten haben und der blick in die
metropolen der welt lässt nichts gutes
erwarten
menschen verschwinden
[Musik]
das öffentliche leben dem stillstand
länder im lockdown jeder für sich und
hinter verschlossenen türen schengen hin
oder her selbst das geeinte europa macht
nun seine grenzen dicht
[Musik]
ja was passierte war dass die
nationalstaaten alle in ihre nationalen
reflexe zurückfielen dass jeder sich
selbst der nächste war in der
europäischen union jedes mitgliedsland
dachte bloß nicht meinem nachbarn maske
liefen lieber den schlagbaum
runtermachen und es kam zu szenen dass
zb an der deutsch französischen grenze
im saarland deutsche franzosen wieder
beschimpften und sagten hier du
dreckiger franzosen mit deinen wir
wieder zurück das war natürlich ein
schock für die eu weil auf einmal die
größte errungenschaft der europäischen
union nämlich das grenzenlose reisen und
das grenzenlose handeln als sich in
gefahr bringen und auch das war ein
schock
in bergamo muss die armee beim laichen
transport helfen und dann die hilferufe
aus den völlig überlasteten
intensivstationen in norditalien
jetzt versteht ganz europa dass jeder
der nächste sein kann
dessen gesundheitssystem kollabiert und
während die nachbarn keine medizinischen
güter exportieren springt china den
bedrängten bei und schickt ausrüstung
und personal und schickt damit einen
spaltpilz nach westen der sofort zu
wirken beginnt
der produktion europäische solidarität
existiert nicht das war nichts weiter
als ein märchen auf papier
ich habe heute einen besonderen brief
geschrieben und darin unsere hoffnung
auf hilfe zum ausdruck gebracht
wir hoffen auf das einzige land das
sonst in dieser schwierigen situation
helfen kann und das ist die
volksrepublik china situationen kenne
was man sehr früh in der chinesischen
politik spürte und bis heute immer
stärker spürt ist das china und vor
allem präsident ski sich hier als ein
weltenlenker präsentieren will
als ein wie man ihn nennt in china onkel
schien es sich um die ganze welt kümmert
und guckt dass jeder seine impfstoffe
kriegt dass jeder seine masken hat china
hilft das ist das bild das man in die
welt projizieren will war ja eigentlich
china auf der anklagebank ein wenig
sitzt die haben man sagt das virus ist
dort ausgebrochen und man hätte
vielleicht mehr gegen das virus
unternehmen können wenn china offensive
mit dem problem umgegangen wären jedes
land geht nun auf seine art mit dem
problem um
der papst gebeten unter einem holzkreuz
das zu bestzeiten wunder gewirkt haben
soll
die indische polizei tanzt dem bollywood
boogie des richtigen händewaschen in
brüssel sind die kommissionspräsidentin
zur selben botschaft die europahymne in
den himmel über der südkoreanischen
hauptstadt seoul schreiben es die
drohnen und der britische premier
erklärt es noch mal langsam für alle
es gibt sicher leute die das nun zum
ersten mal hören waschen sie ihre hände
mit seife und heißem wasser und zwar so
lange wie es dauert zwei mal happy
birthday zu singen
rund um die welt sammeln menschen die so
was nicht gewohnt sind die gleichen
entbehrung erfahrungen hamsterkäufe
schlange stehen erst masken verlachen
dann masken verlangen und klopapier
suchen antike mittelalter oder heute
pandemie verläufe sind immer gleich
sagen historiker im ersten akt wird die
bedrohung ignoriert im zweiten werden
schuldige gesucht und dann im dritten
akt des pandemie dramas entwickeln
regierungen und bevölkerungen eine
antwort auf die bedrohung
wie gehen wir mit der neuen realität um
wie passt das was wir erleben in unsere
kultur und unsere gesellschaft aber
welche antworten sind die richtigen
wer steuert sein schiff am sichersten
durch diesen sturm welche kultur welches
system welche politik jedenfalls fahren
demokratische staaten nicht unbedingt
schlechter als autokratische regime das
haben ja leute mit blick auf china oft
behauptet wenn sie dessen ergebnisse mit
europa und den vereinigten staaten
verglichen haben seit tagen inszenieren
die chinesischen staatsmedien die
rückläufigen infektionszahlen wie einen
trio heute meldet china stolz nur acht
neue fälle in one soll es gerade einmal
vor den augen der gesamten nation werden
dort die provisorischen krankenhäuser
geschlossen
die welt soll sehen dass am ende in
china das virus in den griff bekommt mit
einem lichtspektakel feiert johanna
machten april seine befreiung vom virus
der hausarrest ist beendet aber viele
beschränkungen gelten weiter die
scheinbare rückkehr zum leben vor corona
ist er kauft zum preis totaler kontrolle
und jeder neue ausbruch in china wird
sofort und mit aller härte bekämpft
massentests quarantäne millionenstädte
über nacht im lockdown china ist bisher
deutlich besser durch die krise gekommen
die volkswirtschaft dort wächst schon
seit mit den letzten jahren wieder ganz
ordentlich
zum glück für deutschland weil wir dort
sehr viel ihn exportieren und es führt
natürlich dazu dass china immer
selbstbewusster wird immer
selbstbewusster auftritt
wirtschaftlich aber eben auch
geopolitisch und der hat diese aufstieg
chinas wird durch diese pandemie noch
einmal befeuert die stärkste quelle von
chinas weltweiter wirkung und seines
einflusses ist nun mal seine wirtschaft
und da sie das virus unter kontrolle
gebracht haben sind sie wieder zurück an
dem punkt vor ausbruch der krise
und da sind westliche länder noch lange
nicht und das werden wir noch sehr lange
spüren
manche sagen dass die letzten
kommunistischen staaten also ein
parteien systeme mit freier wirtschaft
china vietnam oder teilweise auf kuba
ganz gut damit fertig werden
aber ich würde die kommunisten nicht zu
sehr preisen denn vergessen sie nicht
einen teil von china gar nicht zu china
gehören will nämlich taiwan geht es noch
besser
und das ist eben nicht kommunistisch
regiert
kein land liegt näher am solchen herd
von johann bis taipeh sind es nicht mal
1000 kilometer
und doch kamen die 23 millionen taiwan
erstaunlich leicht davon
keine 1000 infizierten bis heute und nur
neun patienten starben
ohne lockdown hausarrest beherbergungs
verbote die restaurants blieben geöffnet
und die märkte ebenso
denn taiwan reagierte sehr schnell auch
17 jahre nach dem ausbruch basars noch
nicht vergessen und anders als bei uns
wusste jeder was zu tun war
[Musik]
noch im januar gab es reiseverbote für
china und bald musste jeder ankömmling
14 tage in quarantäne egal woher kam von
anfang an herrschte masken pflicht es
gab keine masken diskussionen und vor
allem gab es auch von anfang an genug
masken und jeder verstand warum er sie
tragen musste alle infektionen wurden
erfasst verfolgt und die quarantäne
überwacht blau sind die verdachtsfälle
in selbst isolierung die wissen wenn sie
ihr haus verlassen dann erfahren wir
dass über ihre smartphones sondern wird
ein bußgeld fällig ich glaube das hat
uns sehr geholfen
das musste es ganz einfach diejenigen
staaten die sofort gesagt haben sarahs
ist zurück also der erreger den wir von
2003 kanten für den wir jahrzehntelang
pandemiepläne gemacht haben auch ich
persönlich und wo man einfach wusste wie
man den im prinzip bekämpfen kann wenn
man gesagt hätte saß ist zurück was
viele staaten gemacht haben dann wären
die maßnahmen richtig ergriffen worden
dann hätte man einfach das anti saas
konzept aus der schublade holen können
sei es dass schwere atemwegs und rom der
vorgänger von sars kopf 2
auch dieses virus entsprang einem
südchinesischen markt und forderte 2003
weltweit fast 800 todesopfer bevor es
plötzlich wieder verschwand
ein nachhaltiger schock in asien
da sind natürlich auch die bevölkerungen
einfach noch viel mehr daran gewöhnt
dass eine solche infektion sich
ausbreiten kann und dass wenn sowas ist
man sich dann einfach ganz strikt an
abstand halten maß getragen und so
weiter hält während in europa anfangs
nicht einmal die gesundheitsminister
abstand wahren und händeschütteln
vermeiden wollten
während in deutschland gesundheitsämter
faxe verschicken
am wochenende ruhen und sich gegen eine
einheitliche software zur kontakt
verfolgung wären
und wo der oberste seuchenbekämpfung
anfangs gar keine gefahr erkennen wollte
aber insgesamt gehen wir davon aus dass
sich das virus nicht sehr stark auf der
welt ausbreitet schließlich waren auch
europas apps unwirksam und verhinderten
nicht die ausbreitung und nicht die
zweite welle wie und zu welchem preis
apps gegen pandemien helfen war in
singapur zu lernen eine der besten
waffen gegen das virus sind diese tracer
die lasten detektivarbeit verfolgen
spuren von infizierten recherchieren
kontakte verordnen quarantäne
wer sich nicht an auflagen hält wird
bestraft ausländer verlieren ihre
arbeitsgenehmigung singapur ist rigoros
dazu technisch auf dem neuesten stand
die regierung hat gerade dazu aufgerufen
eine neue app auf dem smartphone zu
installieren vereinfacht gesagt
verzeichnet sie kontakte mit anderen
personen wenn jemand infiziert das lässt
sich schnell nachvollziehen wer wann wo
wie lange in der nähe war bedenken
werden weggewischt gesundheitsschutz
geht vor datenschutz
singapur ist es tatsächlich kein thema
war es nie ein thema ich gehe gehen mit
ihren daten die natürlich generell
freizügiger um die technik ist weiter
fortgeschritten glaube ich also in
europa man ist gewohnt dass man seine
daten ständig hinterlässt dass man es
benutzt dass man sein handy überall
drauf benutzt das ist selbstverständlich
sozusagen das wurde ja auch nicht groß
gefragt es gibt viele experten mit
möglichkeiten daten nicht nur was die
app angeht sondern auch was das masken
tragen anfangs angeht was verschiedene
andere auflagen angeht die man einhalten
musste da ist singapur ico es werde
dabei erwischt wird fliegt kurzerhand
aus dem land da wird nicht an gefackelt
die strafen sind drakonisch es geht um
viel geld oftmals und wie gesagt man
kann auch schnell die
aufenthaltsgenehmigung verlieren also da
gibt es keine debatte und auch kein
entkommen
selbst das schwellenland vietnam kann
als vorreiter in der pandemie gelten
nicht einmal 40 todesopfer musste es
beklagen dank schneller abschottung
rigoroser kontakt verfolgung massentests
und androhung empfindlicher strafen kaum
etwas das in einer demokratie
vermittelbar gewesen wäre hat der westen
also von vornherein verloren mitbürger
rechtsdenken stadt asiatischen krisen
gehorsam
also es gibt westliche demokratien die
das hervorragend hinbekommen haben
neuseeland ist natürlich das
paradebeispiel aber es gibt zum beispiel
auch das kleine uruguay war es ja
unmittelbar umgeben ist von brasilien
und argentinien zwei länder die das
überhaupt nicht hinbekommen haben der
gemeinsame nenner ist immer dass man
sehr früh und sehr konsequent reagiert
hat das heißt so zu sagen ich glaube die
staatschefin von neuseeland hat gesagt
hit heart and early und ist das prinzip
das man einfach früh und konsequent
durchziehen muss dass es in europa
insbesondere nicht verstanden worden
hier hat man lange diskutiert hier haben
die gesundheitsminister ja so
grundsätzliche maßnahmen beschlossen wie
dass sie sich in zukunft enger
austauschen wollen und solche
allgemeinen vokabeln stadt ganz konkret
zu sagen wir machen jetzt erstmal zu
oder wir testen jetzt erstmal
auch australien konnte mit schneller und
konsequenter politik den kollaps
verhindern nicht verhindern konnte es
lokales wieder aufflammen
das wurde wie zb in melbourne sofort mit
neuem lockdown erstickt
melbourne soll also wieder still alten
mindestens noch drei wochen
erlaubt sind nur wichtige wege zum arzt
zum einkaufen sport
an die vernunft wird appelliert aber
kontrolle scheint besser wenn viele
melbourne lienz spuren nur noch
widerwillig doch verstöße bringen hohe
strafen
also das war eine harte zeit hat
durchaus auch widerstand gegeben
aber im großen und ganzen gerade was
australien und neuseeland betrifft muss
man sagen ziehen die leute mit die
australier feiern sich ein bisschen
selbst dafür inzwischen weil sie
natürlich auch erfolg haben und sagen
dass es unser gemeinsinn darauf bauen
wir unsere nation so zusagen auch dann
halten wir zusammen
und wie gesagt er erfolg hat sich
eingestellt und dann wird es natürlich
auch viel leichter wenn man sieht dass
die dinger einigermaßen funktionieren
zieht man mit aber die diskussion wie
man sie was europa kennt hat man da sony
geführt zwischen den vor allem
asiatischen erfolgsgeschichten und den
vor allem europäischen probleme
erzählungen gibt es die korona mysterien
warum das riesige und arme indien trotz
groben politikversagen es relativ
glimpflich davonkommt
[Musik]
warum in afrika die befürchtete große
katastrophe ausblieb
was an der jungen bevölkerung der
solchen erfahrung oder einfach
mangelndem testmöglichkeiten liegen
könnte
für die einen ein ammenmärchen für die
anderen eine wunder geschichte ist der
schwedische weg zwanglos und ohne
lockdown zur herdenimmunität solche
treffen waren in stockholm nie verboten
discos und clubs sind längst wieder
geöffnet wenn auch unter auflagen
denn bei aller freizügigkeit schweden
hat im verhältnis zur bevölkerungszahl
mindestens dreimal mehr tote zu beklagen
als die eingesperrten nachbarn
wissenschaftler aber glauben an das
konzept der herdenimmunität schweden
zahle zwar jetzt einen hohen preis dafür
doch könne das land vielleicht besser
durch eine mögliche zweite welle der
pandemie kommen als länder die strikte
gegen das virus vorgegangen war
wir alle haben dieses experiment mit
sorge beobachtet und waren eigentlich
der meinung dass das zu riskant ist das
zu machen zumal in schweden die konzepte
für den schutz insbesondere der
altenheime und pflegeheime nicht gut
waren hier quasi die alten menschen ins
risiko zu nehmen die ja eine
sterblichkeit von bis zu zehn prozent
haben wenn sie sich infizieren zugunsten
der gesamtbevölkerung die sich durch
immunisieren soll also aus heutiger
sicht muss man sagen dieser schwedische
weg ist gescheitert wenn auch nicht so
brutal und so grausam gescheitert wie
der brasilianische auch in rio de
janeiro steht das gesundheitswesen kurz
vor dem kollaps
leichen liegen auf den fluren diese
bilder schickt uns ein arzt aus einem
krankenhaus
überfüllte stationen ein beatmungsgerät
für 30 patienten zwischen den lebenden
liegen immer wieder auch tote erzählt er
es ist wie in den krieg zu ziehen wir
sehen dass unsere kollegen krank werden
wir sehen dass unsere kollegen sterben
und wir sehen wie die regierung das
unterschätzt weil der präsident corona
für ein grüppchen hielt und ein anderer
präsident versprach das virus werde auf
wundersame weise einfach verschwinden
und als das nicht passiert erschüttert
er die welt und seine corona
koordinatorin mit neuen ideen
man stelle sich vor wir setzen den
körper einer sehr starken vielleicht
ultravioletten lichtquelle aus sie haben
gesagt das ist noch nicht geprüft worden
aber sie werden es testen und dann sind
da ja noch die desinfektionsmittel die
das virus in einer minute ausschalten
können wir uns das nicht zunutze machen
indem wir es als spritze verabreichen
fast wie eine reinigung
auch als die infektionszahlen
explodieren und mit ihnen die
opferzahlen will trump von masken und
lockt downs nichts wissen
der präsident wickelt sogar die
bevölkerung jener bundesstaaten auf die
das öffentliche leben herunterfahren und
kann sich des beifalls seiner anhänger
sicher sein
sie rufen den schlachthof präsident rob
und sie rufen nach ihren job und ihrem
gewohnten alltag demonstranten von
michigan des kalifornien angestachelt
von internetforen und konservativen
sender
sie wollen uns beherrschen uns
vorschreiben die wir für unsere
gesundheit sorgen dass recht haben sind
wir müssen unsere bürgerrechte
zurückholen und unsere freiheiten die
grippe tötet mehr als corona aber da
wird nicht das gesamte land
runtergefahren
diese art mit der pandemie umzugehen ist
nur eine sehr unglückliche folge eines
tiefgehenden sozialen problems da spielt
ein wirtschaftlicher populismus hinein
weil die gewinne der globalisierung so
ungleich verteilt wurden dann haben
soziale netzwerke und das internet
insgesamt den leuten erlaubt in
alternativen informations galaxien zu
leben
es gibt tatsächlich eine beträchtliche
anzahl von amerikanern die überzeugt
davon sind dass es keine pandemie gibt
sondern nur etwas das ich die gegner von
kramp ausgedacht haben corona leugner
gibt es über alle da mischt sich
verschwörungs glaube mit existenzängsten
realitätsverweigerung mit angst vor
kontrollverlust
ob von trump fans oder selbsternannten
querdenkern auch die auflehnung gegen
die obrigkeit und das system sind
konstanten in der menschheitsgeschichte
der solchen jede epidemie wird begleitet
von sozialen unruhen und aufständen
wir haben das bei der pest erlebt bei
der cholera und auch bei der spanischen
grippe auch die pocken sind ein gutes
beispiel dafür
das liegt daran dass solchen immer die
sozialen unterschiede vergrößern
es ist immer so dass eben manche gruppen
viel schlimmer betroffen sind als andere
wer in einer armen gegend leben muss in
großer engel für den ist es viel
schlimmer
die leute sind immer bereit die
maßnahmen mitzumachen
aber irgendwann kommen sie an den punkt
wo es zu viel wird und dann werden sie
unzufrieden beschweren sich und am ende
begehren sie auch in vielen ländern
flammt widerstand gegen die kuchener
regeln auf
[Musik]
solange der präsident den lockdown nicht
beendet gehen wir hier nicht drängen
herr präsident nehmen sie die verordnung
zurück
wir verlangen dass man uns arbeiten
lässt herr präsident
es muss nicht immer mit straßenkämpfen
und plünderungen enden so wie im sommer
der protest der händler in paraguay es
kann auch ganz still und anmutig
daherkommen so wie die italienischen
hochzeitsplaner die haben wie die ganze
veranstaltungswirtschaft den untergang
vor augen die cola pandemie hat
wirtschaftlich unsere gesellschaft stark
gespalten
für viele menschen in deutschland für
viele beschäftigte hat sich
wirtschaftlich wenig geändert die haben
nach wie vor ihr einkommen aber es gibt
halt vor allem menschen mit geringen
einkommen geringen qualifikationen die
in dieser pandemie besonders stark
gelitten haben
nehmen wir als beispiel 850.000
minijobberinnen minijobber nehmen sie
die 2.500 solo selbstständigen
mittlerweile häufig gar nichts mehr zu
tun aber eher wenig zu tun haben und
leiden die schere ist weiter aufgegangen
sei es bei den einkommen oder am
arbeitsmarkt sei es im bildungsbereich
bei dem kinder vor allem aus
einkommensschwachen bildungsfernen
familien hinten runter fallen aber auch
regeln als von den flamenco tänzer in
barcelona über die restaurantbetreiber
in paris
und die nachtclub besitzer in portugal
für die gefahr kommen sieht bald alles
zu verlieren
dem fällt es immer schwerer ruhig zu
halten
und irgendwann rufen sie nach dem ende
von corona terror und corona tyrannei
sowie anfang januar in prag und
betrachten die behörden als feind sie
sagen ja nicht dass kubicki nicht
existiert sie sagen viel mehr wenn wir
kobe zu ernst nehmen mit all den
medizinischen problemen
dann ist das eine bedrohung nicht nur
für die freiheit sondern ganz konkret
für unsere art zu leben
ich verstehe diese leute wir erleben ja
wirklich massive einschnitte
ich glaube nicht dass das so schnell
vorbeigeht
ich glaube wie der französische
philosoph bruno latour das comic nur die
generalprobe ist für zukünftige krisen
vielleicht noch weitere pandemien oder
der klimawandel und so weiter ich glaube
die menschheit befindet sich an der
schwelle zu einem neuen zeitalter
ein zeitalter der spaltung spätestens
als in den niederlanden jugendliche
gegen die ausgangssperren randalierten
wurde noch ein corona schlachtfeld
eröffnet der kampf der generationen in
dieser pandemie wächst die kluft
zwischen den baby boom an und den
millenniums von den jungen wird verlangt
dass sie viele einschränkungen hinnehmen
obwohl sie von der krankheit gar nicht
so sehr betroffen sind
das dient dem schutz der älteren
generation und das führt zu reibungen
zwischen den beiden berg viele die den
ersten lockdown noch hinnahmen wollen
kein zweiter mehr erleben sei es nun in
spanien oder in italien oder auch bei
uns
andere unterstützen die maßnahmen und so
driften gesellschaften innerlich
auseinander und verlieren ihr
wichtigstes bindemittel das vertrauen
was wir aber auch gleichzeitig sehen ist
das in dem augenblick wo wir auch
kontrolle setzen und wo der andere der
der andere mensch zu einer gefahr für
uns wird wir eben dieses erste
funktionsprinzip moderner gesellschaften
das erstmal das vertrauen ist in
gewisser weise aushebeln und sagen der
mensch ist des menschen wolf ja wir sind
uns gegenseitig gefährlich und deshalb
brauchen wir den starken staat dem wir
uns unterwerfen müssen damit wir
einigermaßen sicher leben können also
man kann menschen auch die mündigkeit
und die eigenverantwortung abtrainieren
indem man ihnen eben immer wieder vor
augen hätte aber du willst doch auch
sicher sein du willst dich doch auch
sicher fühlen das ist aber genau das
lockmittel auch von autokratischen
staaten und das müssen wir glaube ich
immer im blick behalten also dieses
versprechen der sicherheit das ist immer
auch das versprechen der autokratie es
gibt tatsächlich eine menge politiker
überall in der welt die sich die
pandemie zu nutze gemacht haben um ihre
macht zu erweitern und irland in eine
autoritäre richtung zur meine frau
nehmen sie viktor orban in ungarn mit
seiner notstandsbefugnisse aber auch el
salvador uganda ebenso china das hat im
windschatten der pandemie seien
sicherheitsgesetz auf hongkong
ausgeweitet man kann sich nicht einfach
hinstellen und sagen china hat gewonnen
china hat gewonnen mit dem brutalen
einsatz der herrschenden kommunistischen
partei elite die größte herausforderung
für europa ist nun kann sie diese
pandemie bezwingen und uns vorbereiten
für künftige katastrophen ohne
chinesische methoden anzuwenden
davon hängt europas überleben ab
gibt es heilung vom virus und seinen
nebenwirkungen
[Musik]
gegen das virus kommt der impfstoff so
schnell wie noch nie
einer der ganz wenigen globalen
lichtblicke der pandemie
[Musik]
die wissenschaft hat extrem schnell
reagiert wir haben ein paar ganz schlaue
köpfe gehabt die sofort die werkzeuge
zur verfügung stehen
verwendet haben neue impfstoffe zu
generieren um möglichst schnell sehr
sehr viel über das virus zu lernen und
alle haben und das ist neu wir wissen
ganz bei ausgetauscht drei wochen vor
allen anderen beginnt großbritannien mit
der kampagne nach dem break sieg müssen
die briten auf niemanden mehr warten
die eu kann das tempo nicht mithalten
was wieder viel ansehen und vertrauen
kostete das 27 länder zusammen mit der
eu-kommission verhandelt haben hat
natürlich zeit gekostet weil die kosten
kommission immer wieder rückkoppeln
musste natürlich waren sie sich nicht
einig die osteuropäer haben gesagt und
die preise das aber teuer
die bulgaren haben gesagt minus 70 grad
wie sollen wir das denn transportieren
das geht ja gar nicht
die franzosen haben gesagt wir haben
dann prima konzern der heißt sanofi bei
dem sollten wir bestellen die schweden
haben gesagt es ist wahnsinnig gut also
natürlich hat das lange gedauert und
ganz ehrlich wenn wir uns jetzt so
rückwirkend betrachten dann ist es
eigentlich ein erfolg dass die 27
mitgliedsstaaten zusammen verträge
geschlossen haben mit sechs impfstoff
herstellern und tatsächlich relativ
einig jedenfalls ein großer fortschritt
gegenüber den tagen als man sich
gegenseitig die schutzmasken
wegschnappte
aber in einer welt in der das virus die
spielregeln diktieren kann selbst ein
politischer erfolg im fiasko enden und
ein wissenschaftlicher erfolg von kurzer
dauer sein besonders wenn das virus
mutiert und die spielregeln ändert sorge
in europa eine corona mutation in
großbritannien soll deutlich
ansteckender sein
sorge macht den südafrikanern eine neue
mutierte variante des virus die noch
ansteckender zu sein scheint als die
alte und auch von einer brasilianischen
mutante wird bald die rede sein
die kommt aus manaus am amazonas wo man
schon glaubte dank vieler infektionen
die ersehnte herdenimmunität erreicht zu
haben
stattdessen neue wellen von infektionen
und neue wellen von angst und
abschottung
wieder werden grenzen geschlossen
nachbarn riskiert vertrauen verspielt
und ein ende kommt nicht in sicht weil
ja niemand weiß wo die nächsten mutanten
lauern
ich kann diesen schritt nachvollziehen
dass man aus angst vor mutationen jetzt
grenzen schließt und einreiseverbote
ausspricht ich glaube nur wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht in eine krise
fixierung herein geraten aus der wir
letzten endes nie wieder rauskommen und
das kann man sagen ist die gefahr die
man jetzt gut beobachten kann ja jetzt
jetzt gehen die infektionszahlen runter
jetzt jetzt ins aber die mutanten die
uns neue sorgen bereiten
und die frage ist wird es denn jemals
den punkt geben wo wir ganz und gar
sorgenfrei einfach sagen können so und
jetzt fängt das alte leben wieder an das
glaube ich nicht ich glaube es wird
immer risiken und drohende krisen und
drohende katastrophen geben aber wir
müssen wir dürfen eben in die zukunft
als möglichkeit frauen nicht ganz und
gar aus dem blick verlieren wir müssen
leider für die zukunft den menschen die
wahrheit sagen dass auch mit der impfung
und auch mit zunehmenden natürlichen
infektionen wenn nicht in einen zustand
kommen werden wie der manchmal so
suggeriert wird dann sind wir alle immun
dann haben wir die härten immunität und
dann ist der spuk vorbei
das virus wird bleiben das wird sich
weiter verändern in verschiedenen
varianten das heißt aber auch die die
ansteckungsfähigkeit wird sozusagen
herunter gehen also die explosionsartige
verbreitung wird sich reduzieren und
dann wird das so ähnlich sein wie eine
schwere influenza man will das sicher
vermeiden aber man wird deswegen keine
locker uns mehr machen aber man muss
sagen die hans natürlich durch unsere
lebensform den viren auch leicht gemacht
sich schnell auszubreiten wir leben
extrem dicht beieinander
da ist es natürlich super durch eine
ganze eng besiedelte gegend
durchzuziehen wir reisen extrem wie
antiviren die reisen einfach mit uns mit
über die grenzen hinweg unser unsere
stadien sind wir viel größer als die
kopieren jahren
all das werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht
wieder zurückbauen können infektionen
sind nicht weg das hatten wir gehofft
vielleicht auch geglaubt und haben jetzt
schmerzhaft lernen müssen dass es eben
nicht mehr ganz in der geschichte keinen
epidemien so viel häufiger vor als heute
wir hatten einfach glück dass die letzte
pandemie 100 jahre zurückliegt im
mittelalter da kam die pest alle neun
jahre zu und jeder ist mindestens einmal
im leben durch eine bestzeit gegangen
mit so etwas können wir heute gar nicht
mehr umgehen solchen haben keinen platz
mehr in unserem bewusstsein und wir
wissen nicht wie wir sie anpacken soll
wir haben verlernt mit risiken zu leben
und mit der tatsache dass wir an einer
seuche sterben könnten
wir können das nicht akzeptieren früher
mussten sie damit leben
das erste jahr der pandemie brachte uns
vom markt den bubis an den saum einer
möglichen dritten welle zu neuen grenzen
und zu alten ängsten
es war im chinesischen kalender das jahr
der ratte und es hat die welt erschreckt
und angenagt
20.21 begrüßten die chinesen das jahr
des ochsen im volksglauben vergehen die
langsam und zäh erfordern ruhe kraft und
ausdauer und sind unendlich mühevoll
[Musik]